[Musique]
la certitude il y en a c'est grey
il y à l'intégrer sénatrice italienne de
89 ans reçoit aujourd'hui la médaille
d'or de la croix rouge
il y a deux mois elle a été nommée à la
tête d'une toute nouvelle commission de
lutte contre le racisme et l'incitation
à la haine
cette survivante d'auschwitz a commencé
à recevoir des centaines de messages
antisémites et des menaces de mort elle
vit aujourd'hui sous la protection
constante de la police cela mérite au
veston comme aide à les parents l'est
les patients familles et qu'on ne suis
pas sympa dépôts et des featurettes
[Musique]
c'est sur ce quai de la gare de milan en
1943 liliana âgée de 13 ans a été
embarqué à bord d'un wagon plombé en
compagnie de son père
direction à auschwitz
une des rares survivantes italienne elle
en est revenue seule un numéro de
matricule tatoué sur son bras
les paroles et de l'audio que pour son
audace et c'est vrai
nico a déclaré personae marqué soldats
polynésiens courage et d'esprit
gad lerner est un des journalistes les
plus connus de l'italie éditorialiste
animateur de télévision auteur de livres
juifs
il a aussi été victime d' attaques
racistes ces derniers mois juif retourne
chez toi tu n'es pas italien c'est avec
des cris hostiles du genre qu'il a été
accueilli récemment dans des assemblées
de la lègue à la ligue un parti
d'extrême droite qu'il observe depuis 30
ans kerno desprès la ligue a toujours
utilisé un langage méprisant l'endroit
des gens du sud de l'italie et des
immigrantes cela était sous-estimé mais
à long terme cela produit une escalade
verbale qui peut vite passer à la
violence physique
et voici matteo salvini le chef de la
ligue
jusqu'au mois d'août dernier vice
premier ministre et ministre de
l'intérieur
son gouvernement est tombé mais lui
reste le politicien le plus populaire du
tali g l'interpeller sur l'orientation
de son parti et canada se commande pas
c'est un manque criant partie des belles
âmes à la souterraine votre ligue turque
ou pierre mondy d'abord dit à ce sont
des passionnés d'histoire la diabline
discours s et non je coupe la monnaie du
fascisme et au communisme
des milliers de femmes sont venues ici à
florence pour applaudir celui qui veut
débarrasser l'italie des demandeurs
d'asile fermer ses ports aux réfugiés de
la mer et tourner le dos à l'union
européen
[Applaudissements]
sa vie est en campagne électorale
permanente les prochaines élections
régionales sont en janvier et voilà les
sardines ces dizaines de milliers de
manifestants qui spontanément
envahissent les places des deals
italienne depuis quelques semaines
alors que matteo salvini rencontre ses
supporters une foule de quarante mille
personnes est descendu sur la place de
la république à florence
[Musique]
nous avons rencontré les jeunes
organisateurs de la manifestation
politique
bien que notre mouvement ne soit lié à
aucun parti politique
la droite représentée par matteo salvini
prendre des valeurs contraires
il veut les pleins pouvoirs mais la
concentration des pouvoirs entre les
mains d'une seule personne va à
l'encontre de notre constitution et de
la démocratie
la ligue de matteo salvini est
aujourd'hui le premier parti d'italie
elle vient de gagner haut la main les
élections régionales en ombrie au nord
de rome dans la capitale perouse connu
pour la beauté de sa vie ville et son
fameux chocolat beaucoup d'ouvriers de
perugia traditionnellement à gauche ont
voté pour la ligue
on a besoin d'un changement dit elle on
avait la gauche ici depuis tellement
d'années
la ligue a gagné beaucoup de points ici
chez les ouvriers avec les thèmes comme
l'immigration qui sont importants pour
nous a terni la grande ville
industrielle de la région dont
l'économie a souffert au cours des
dernières années
cet ancien ouvrier de l'usiné
sidérurgique fondateur de la ligue ici
explique machine fascisme extrême droite
ce n'est pas ça qui est important
le problème c'est que les gens
n'arrivent plus financièrement les voir
sur l'avant ils pouvaient aller manger
de la pizza en famille une fois par
semaine aujourd'hui ce n'est même plus
une fois par mois la région de l'ombrie
vote à gauche depuis plus de 50 ans
cette année son économie mal en point
elle a élu la ligue en alliance avec un
parti néofasciste frères d'italie
directement inspirée de benito mussolini
dans la ville de bologne capitale de la
région d'emilie romagne
ce conseiller municipal membre des
frères d'italie voudrait voir son pays
débarrassé des réfugiés avec un collègue
député du même parti au parlement
national
ils se sont rendus dans ce quartier
populaire où il ya beaucoup de logements
sociaux
ils ont lu à voix haute les noms à
consonance étrangère affichés sur les
listes des locataires le tout était
diffusé en direct sur facebook
il disait protester ainsi contre
l'attribution des logements à prix
modique à des étrangers plutôt qu'à des
italiens nous sommes allés décrire la
situation actuelle du logement social
60% des nouveaux appartements sont
attribués à des étrangers
c'est une bataille historique son parti
dont la popularité a doublé au cours de
la dernière année considère les
étrangers comme une menace directe à
l'identité italienne
nous sommes pour le crucifix dans les
classes pour les valeurs qui sont les
nôtres
la famille traditionnelle avec un père
et une mère héritier du fascisme les
frères d'italie en aucun cas selon lui
le fascisme et mais il est mort avec
benito mussolini
pour cet observateur de longue date de
la droite italienne le climat a
nettement changé depuis quelques temps
une diffusion de haine et aussi de
violences physiques contre les africains
contre les musulmans contre les dips et
qui est beaucoup plus fort que non ce
que moi je vais risques et les coûts
john ani ou art dans la télévision lui
les miss amérique ouest
campagne
peyrelongue y en un sursaut l'italienne
quelques animaux l'économie mais
l'italie n'a pas dit son dernier mot
début décembre des maires de 600 villes
italiennes ont manifesté à milan leur
soutien à liliana sait gré elle est sous
notre protection ont-ils scandé
la haine n'a pas d'avenir
[Musique]